[Music]
three
two one action hey guys welcome back to
up the record we talk about
whatever we want [ __ ]
why they [ __ ] um i wasn't talking
about them
sorry if i offended you guys i just like
saying things like that like fool
like i don't really mean it i got in
trouble for saying fool uh
in school because you know how like you
said that to your friends back in the
day like hey what's up fool and all that
and then my teacher was like joseph you
shouldn't call people
a fool dude my mom used to get mad at me
if i said shut up to my brothers and
sisters but then she's on the phone my
aunt and she's like shut up and i'm like
wow
[Laughter]
shut up her i don't know [ __ ]
yeah that's way worse that was not a
question oh that's true that's true i
made up my own
uh shut up or fool is that what i
feel like it depends on intention but i
think shut up hurts the feelings more
yeah really as a as a new parent if
someone was like hey you fool
and it's like so i feel like as a parent
as long as they're not saying the f word
it's cool
wow so everything about between the [ __ ]
tigers got it good
no tiger says the f-word though i know
so so that's the only time i correct
them
oh he doesn't say it properly though i
think i think he could say way better
with more
yeah he's a habitual line stepper like
me so what he really likes to say is um
pinche madre is something something
something it's a whole phrase yeah
yeah some a whole phrase but then now
he'll be playing he'll be like
pinch pink
and he adds a syllable yeah where did he
learn that from i don't know you know
pinch is like
pretty much like the effort equivalent
of
yeah in spanish i just don't get how
kids like they can hear every word and
not say it and then they hear one and
they don't know the context behind it
yeah and they're like that just sounds
nice that's the one and they keep saying
it yeah why do we all say [ __ ] because
it does feel good it does feel so good
like the way uh when bitcoin went to 40
000 i was like
21 000 dude
come on listen i don't know everyone
doubted me everyone hated on me for
years
i know i know i'm talking about my
mainly people who watch the show
yeah the [ __ ] all over me they're still
talking [ __ ] about it no but there's
people that that that are in crypto too
that that are fans and they're with us
that's true i like the i like you're
talking about the naysayers yeah who
said it's a big scam and how high the
ponzi bubble
yeah they're like guess what the ponzi
is back
or last year they were like oh it's
gonna it's gonna it's never gonna hit
20k again right these are idiots it's
gonna drop and then now when it's
hitting 40k
they're like oh it's just it's gonna
drop watch i'm like okay like
sell it make money like just zoom out of
yourself and go like wait am i
do i sound like legit now you know what
i mean they never do
no yeah so where do you think it's going
to head 200
000 by the end of this actually explain
the end of this month no end of this run
i was like damn i was like i'll jump
only believe that if i had just done a
line of coke and i'm like 200 000.
yeah end of the month well you were like
omg's going to go to another coin
was going to go to 10 well it did and it
did and we just didn't sell it
i i sold at five good job yeah it was
that like
i lost over 10. it was it was at 28.
yeah
it was a 28. oh but years ago years ago
yeah
that one we just [ __ ] up that one why
it's such a big deal that bitcoin is
is a certain amount if there's like a
million other coins
okay so crypto is a market living
breathing market just like
stocks wall street all that [ __ ] but
wall street and those guys they look at
and go that's a ponzi it's all [ __ ]
well they buy
crypto right by crypto giant
institutions that have come in to buy
crypto so yes and including elon musk he
just said he wanted to look at taking
the tesla order
books or whatever the [ __ ] like a bunch
of money basically and throw it into
bitcoin
so um but the reason why bitcoin being
back is such a huge indicator is because
the alts are also part of bitcoin the
ethereum's part of
bitcoin they all kind of move together
eventually bitcoin's kind of i've always
described it as the plow that moves
the clears the road for the rest of the
crypto market it's like the gold
exactly exactly like silver platinum and
all these other things yeah but there's
other coins that are more expensive or
we're more expensive
no no not the bitcoin nothing's over
forty thousand i'm not saying now but
like a month ago
no no you're thinking of um like you're
in finance
bitcoin dominance or no i'm just saying
in terms of like coins that are more
expensive
oh oh yeah no but as far as market cap
nothing is past bitcoin like as far as
like because yeah you you could have a
coin that's worth more than 20. but no
one's trading it 10 of them
right right now there's like metal is
more expensive than gold two but gold
sets the trend or
standard and it's worth more together if
you big put a big bottle of gold
together it's worth more altogether than
some gem you know that that's all
but yeah so that's why everyone's
excited because now the market is is
jumping is roaring back
obviously bitcoin like everyone's
talking about it right now
and that's when the fomo starts to build
some banks like jp morgan chase thinks
it could hit 600 in like three years
what do you think about that
yeah i mean i'm one of those people who
who thinks bitcoin will be at a million
dollars eventually yeah
i absolutely believe that what was the
former the former ceo
was uh chase something that was it jamie
dimon right
he used to call it a fraud he had all
this [ __ ] and he got caught
with this bitcoin in his portfolio he
resigned
but now he makes a claim that bitcoin is
going to skyrocket to 150
000 so for all the people that are like
oh
it's whack or whatever think about it
these guys
that are ceos of banks and they're not
[ __ ] financial idiots
right and like if they were why would
they be getting into this
dude i have referral bitcoin just from
like years ago getting like my family
into bitcoin that's worth like thousands
of dollars right now
just from like 20 bucks to you 20 bucks
a year 20 bucks two but it was so low
back then compared to now like it's just
ridiculous like how
how much how scarce it is that's what
i'm more interested in than the price
it's scarce
it's only there's only ever going to be
20 million something bitcoins ever
and you know mine for more if they're
like they're not all taken up yet no
it's harder to mine they slowly get
mined out every single day and then
um there's a thing called the happening
which is what i was trying to tell
everybody
a couple months ago um in just in
2020 is once the happening happens that
means every day
there's less bitcoin that can be mined
and so that's when
the market starts to switch back from
being bear market to bull market and
that's what happened
it's not because i know everything it's
because i've seen it all happen before
it's just history
it always hits like its highest peak a
year after that yeah exactly
yeah roughly yeah so it's like right now
it's only like a few months away from
last year's happening
uh no no so the next happening is i
think no i'm saying it's only
it's only a few months away from last
year's having yes exactly having happens
every four years
i don't know if it's every four years
every four years is it it was last time
was 2016 and then 2017
when it hit 19. but is it
algorithmically every four years or is
it more
no it's it's every four years and then
every time it happens it's
half the amount of bitcoin so i think it
was like 12. bitcoin per like per day
per ledger that was able to get like
to these miners and then now it's six so
every four years because of
elections no every four years because of
how uh what's the guy's name satoshi
designed it
i didn't know it was locked into years
though it's interesting i thought it had
something that's 2012
2016 2020. they do that to keep it
scarce and make
like it was supposed to be like an
automated
i guess quality control or like a way to
not
um not dump the mark not dump it all in
the market and get it bought up quickly
i see so it's like like siphoning it
slowly if you wanted to destroy bitcoin
and you're some bank you could just buy
up the entire [ __ ] supply and now you
run bitcoin but they can't do that
because bitcoin is getting issued daily
yeah so so that's a totally different
thing they really thought this through
it's crazy
he's a genius he or she or whoever or
the team or yeah or the cia who knows he
could be dead
oh yeah yeah i mean he's probably if you
do make the argument though that it's
not a sound investment or it's not
safe or whatever yeah i i i totally
agree like it's
it's volatile it's crazy it's like it's
it's
it's it'd be it's closer to gambling
than it is to investing
that's why it makes it fun that's that's
true but it's everybody but slower penny
stocks
so are like you know but you can say
that right but it's also
got a utility and a value like like i
can send the dean money right now
without anybody's permission and that
has a real value like a lot of people
see that as valuable especially if you
live somewhere where
signing up to a bank is not easy these
[ __ ] african scammers they switch to
instead of sending you money or send me
money send me a bitcoin is that right
yeah
they don't ask for money anymore just go
to your spam because it's untraceable
yeah
yeah i wish i didn't believe into like
these people like all the people that
leave the comments like it's a scam
i was like i believed into that years
ago and we had one of our co-workers
a little kid that just we didn't trust
and he [ __ ] was like telling us
everyday buy bitcoin buy bitcoin but
he made like 10 mil he made seven mil
seven million no way
yeah wait what you guys probably met him
before too wait
what he was trying to tell everybody to
buy bitcoin but no one believed
early ish not early early like
early middle it was like 2016.
wait so he made seven million dollars
and then yeah he just started rolling up
in lambos and
what the [ __ ] that's kinda oh [ __ ]
i mean he's gonna get lit think about it
right like this happened
with the dot-com boom in silicon valley
like that was there like the 80s era or
90s era or whatever right
like when that happened you could have
made a [ __ ] ton of money too but you had
to sell
because if you held too long you were
[ __ ] but it depends on what you chose
it's like aol was hot for a minute but
where the [ __ ] is aol now
right but even apple just crashed like
last march
right and but now but then it rose back
up so it's
bitcoin like it went down in march but
then it went past the all-time high and
if you zoom out of the chart it just
looks like a ladder going up the whole
yeah so it's the same kind of thing
because it has a real world value i
think i don't think it's just something
that goes
up and then completely crashes because
if you look at daily volume bitcoin's
always being used always being
transparent if you talk about
solely bitcoin maybe but then
everything and everything else like i
would say
compared to a blue chip stock right
it's still not it's all speculation so
like
it's not it's not a company it's not
amazon it's not
tesla it's like you're still it's still
way more aggressively
risky and i think that people that are
afraid of it
if they make that argument that makes
sense but if people go oh it's just a
[ __ ] scam it's like well
yeah you don't know anytime i hear about
bitcoin and then now the fact that it's
worth so much money i can't help
but feel like [ __ ] man i should have
bought some when my mom told me about
this [ __ ]
years ago because she told me what they
should tell you it was like almost 10
years ago
like she was telling me she was like 100
bucks back
dollars she was literally telling me
remember oh yeah that's when i first saw
it
there's old tweets there's old tweets
that like because i fought like a bunch
of like stock and whatever
ig's and they'll find old tweets of
people and some of the tweets would be
like
[ __ ] i bought bitcoin at eight bucks and
i sold it at 12.
oh [ __ ] yeah but then i think about all
that and i'm like
holy [ __ ] cause my mom always gets
caught up in scammy [ __ ] and i'm like
this is the one thing that she was right
about i get so stressed
i wish i had something that can calm
because you never know you don't know
you don't know what happened you could
have sold it you could have sold it at
200.
i know something because all of this
trading sometimes gives me anxiety
me too and you know what this video is
brought to you
by feels thank you very much for
sponsoring this video
but feels is an awesome premium cbd
delivered directly to your doorstep and
they've been giving me
some delicious good old cbd oils
and lately with the excitement of
bitcoin and things like that i do get
glued to my phone
and i'm looking around looking at like
all of my trades and i'm going damn
that's a lot of money that's negative in
on the red
or i go damn that's too exciting because
it's all green today
but there comes a time when i need to go
to sleep
and come over to jk news and talk to you
guys
and i can't do that usually unless i get
a few drops of seal
uh i get a few drops of fields put it
into my tongue
and then it helps me relax and i have
like a nighttime ritual
or i go like that chill out maybe not
think about crypto
maybe watch a puppy jump inside of snow
or something like that you know
and relax my mind and then it helps me
knock the hell out so it's a prettier
it's a pretty awesome thing and i feel
like it's a good way to unwind
at the end of the day and what does
fields do
it feel feels naturally helps reduce
stress anxiety pain and sleeplessness
it's easy to take place a few drops of
fields under your tongue and feel the
difference within minutes the thing to
remember about cbd
is that finding your right dose is
important so leave room to experiment
over the course of a week or so
you may need to take more or less to get
the effects you're after
so if you're new to cbd feels offers a
free cbd hotline to help guide your
personal experience and feels works
naturally to help you feel better
there's no high hangover or addiction
join the fields community get feels
delivered to your door
every single month you'll save money on
every order and you can pause or cancel
at any time then you can also depend on
it because it's scheduled
make sure you become a member and get 50
off your first order become a member and
get 50
off your first order thank you to fields
for sponsoring off the record
yeah you're right i could have sold it
at 200. yay
yeah who's gonna sit there and hold it
no matter the [ __ ] what and then like
ride it all the way to
now forty thousand did your mom believe
in herself did she have her own bitcoin
um i think she did something she didn't
keep it
see she didn't even believe it no but
i'm telling you like
my poor mom she always gets scammed like
oh
she's just like so susceptible to
getting you were you the one that talked
her out of bitcoin
um i didn't talk her out of it but i was
just like i don't know mom
you always get involved in shady [ __ ]
like without knowing like are you sure
like do your research and she was like
no mika this is really like this is
legit she had an
app and like she actually was like yeah
see and she showed me in person like see
it's a hundred dollars like bitcoin's a
hundred like it's only a hundred dollars
i forgot how much it's funny because in
both situations you
we're told about bitcoin from people you
just cannot trust because they never do
[ __ ] right right
and then they actually told you the
right [ __ ] and you're looking back like
what the [ __ ] yeah
because i'm always gonna be the thing is
uh
i was curious about bitcoin too when i
was doing it
or when i was getting into it it was
like a thousand-ish and during that time
i think we just barely met steve or like
nikki was telling us
about bitcoin or something like that it
was it was kind of like in the air i
remember hearing a thousand and going
[ __ ] that that's too much money yeah but
i had a i had a routine where like every
every december so i would buy gold it
was about the same price
so at that time i bought about like
20 bars or 20 you know uh 20 ounces it's
about like 20
000 ish right so i was like oh yeah well
i could get bitcoin but i don't really
understand the process
and then several months later um i think
ethereum hit because of
because of the whole run right and
that's when you came up
and i was like so you made how much and
then i started to listen i started to
research and i was like
oh okay okay we're still early because
this was like 2017
january-ish still early or was it 2016.
it was still before the run
it was 2017 early though yeah so then i
started
accumulating right and then we got into
like another coin but
in between that process i recently went
back to
kind of like figure out what i did and
i'm like
all of that bitcoin that i transferred
over if i held that
yeah oh look at that 1.5 million damn
you looked at your old transactions yeah
oh [ __ ]
because you know you have to use bitcoin
back then to transact to
buy other coins yeah yeah i'm like damn
but then what i also realized is that
like a lot of
investing or just i don't know i gamble
i don't invest
but this is it's a lot of it is um it's
psychological right it's like dealing
with foam all dealing like
when is it enough like for example some
people
um they bought it at three thousand or
five thousand and then they sold at
twenty thousand
and they're kicking themselves in their
asses because they're like i could have
waited till forty
but they should and they should but to
me i'm like you yeah
no you you won you [ __ ] won you got
nothing that's right
i see a lot of a lot of our friends that
get into stocks as well like you guys
are or at least nikki like she's really
into it and i'm like
she's doing it the right way too no for
sure she's super educated
like i'm sure she's doing it exactly how
she should but for me personally because
i know i'm not going to put the time and
effort into doing the research
i am i'm just afraid of [ __ ] up and
i'm
perfect for you then are you kidding me
you just [ __ ] buy it and you [ __ ]
chill
not now yes you know yes you do you can
buy it now or you can wait because
just based on the charts and trends like
it's gonna come back down eventually we
don't know like what the high i think
the high will be that's what a financial
advisor is for
quick run here's my money please invest
it
right now yeah [ __ ] that are there
financial advisors for crypto
like actually his name is steve green
he's sitting right here in the room
and i think how many clients do you have
um
my phone blows you every referral i
don't know about that steve
he's getting commissioned and he's
helping all of us absolutely steve has
never steered me wrong
and steve was like if you put into this
one coin it was 50 cents when we talked
about it
within a month it was ten dollars boom
tight boom
i did it of course
you know what steve's never wronged
about the coin
he's wrong about when you should sell
because he never tells you to sell i'm a
believer i'm a believer
but you know what that's true i've
i have adjusted that strategy
but no no i mean it's a learning process
right no one knows everything
yeah that's right exactly but that's
another thing too because we haven't
sold our [ __ ]
and i also i don't ever also believe in
like
putting like not that we're blaming
steve roter but i don't think you ever
believe in blaming anyone on anything
because i don't
like your blame because at the end of
the day it's your decision you make your
own decisions and
if you're not gonna if steve tells you
something and you don't go out and do
your own research
then that's your fault for just trusting
one person for making it
absolutely i'm like i want to [ __ ] with
stuff and people are constantly learning
right so like at the time i mean this
was a joke but at the time i understand
steve psychology because
we were in it for the long term of it
not the trading of it
so then if there was a huge chance
of this company if it did get into
practical use in
asia it made a lot of sense
but if you look at it now from a
trader's point of view
or just a just a conservative investor's
point of view
that was extremely reckless yes so there
was
so there were like average basic things
that we should have done like taking out
principle done this or whatever
right it's like money off the table as
you're winning yeah but then if you're
like
all in every time in a hand of poker
you're gonna probably lose your stack
you know what i mean i do think
so people understand like say bitcoin it
does like run the market and it's like
the highest like
like volume and everything but if you're
in a coin that's
probably that all these coins are coming
up you do your research like say like
the omg coin that you always talk about
if that coin i was in from 50 cents to
10
that would have made me way more money
than being in a
bitcoin at ten thousand dollars that's
also called gambling but what i'm saying
is like there's still opportunities for
people to make money that do have that
phone being like i can never get into
this
oh yeah there's other altcoins and it's
also it's still at its infancy
it was but the reason why i was like yo
nadim this is this thing's worth sense
right now and i know it's going to ten
dollars
is because i knew about the news that
was coming out and that's what i was
telling everybody about it's like
oh just wait i was telling casey and
june i was like this thing's about to
explode out of the [ __ ] bottom of
this thing
how do you find that kind of news like
the truth they'll just follow this stuff
like i do read it [ __ ] i i read
all this [ __ ] all the time like for me i
think i'm way behind joe and steve on
his knowledge stuff but at least for me
i still want to be
up to date so you can just even on
instagram i started following a bunch of
crypto
in finance stock igs and just even just
through memes and then going through
signing up to their newsletters you just
start understanding more and more and
more
and while i'm personally not in the omg
coin anymore
i still think people who are in it will
do fine i just would rather be with
something that has less
of a history to it now i want to be in
like the new
new hype coins because your strategy has
changed to being more of a trader
yeah like or short term trader versus
like
long term hold buy and hold like the
warren buffett style
of like i believe in this company and i
think i'm buying it cheap and then it's
gonna blow the [ __ ] up yeah
so like uh i mean you know there is no
right or wrong way i think
people that made the right moves
and then they look back they can say i
did all the right things
but like no one knows while they're
doing it a thousand percent
no way and anyone who says they do is
full of [ __ ]
but you if you but if you it's easy to
look smart when it when you want
yeah and if you but if you follow the
market and look at it as a cycle
and you go okay so this is what tends to
happen you can make smart moves and
that's all
depending on elon musk tweeting out [ __ ]
someone or smoking weed and
you lose hundreds of thousands of
dollars oh like the stock market yeah
no like he did with tesla right yeah
yeah that was classic
yeah it also rebounded like right after
that right yeah but i'm saying like you
can lose so much just by a tweet
yeah it's crazy
you